cono health who is sponsoring this
segment has a different way of treating
patients the goal is to get patients
healthy and not just prescribe
medication here to tell us more is dr
richard aguilera and dr prabhu welcome
to show you guys great to be here jason
okay let's start talking uh first who do
you provide service to
las vegas we're talking seniors or is a
british clientele that you guys direct
your services to you no jc you're
absolutely right dr prabhu whatever
probably how many years have you been
here in las vegas 40 years 40 years
imagine how many people have seen dr
brooke for 40 years i've been in
practice not quite that long 35 years
but most of the patients we see not
because we're older and gray are the
senior popular the medicare advantage 65
and older they have high blood pressure
and diabetes sometimes we see that all
the time yes
and what kind of services do you provide
you provide everything or the particular
services that you provide well dr babu
and i are primary care clinicians and so
we treat the blood pressure issues and
diabetes in fact here in las vegas in
the state of nevada there's a quarter of
a million people who have diabetes in
fact ten thousand are diced every single
year wow the amazing thing is so many
people don't know about it and so we at
canada health in fact 93 of all our
clinicians in cano are
recognized by the national community
quality insurance for outstanding
diabetes control and care so we want to
recognize the audience for coming to see
us like your general mechanic get your
tires changed your oil change rotate
things and we can tune up your car so
why is that some doctors they do that
they throw medication at the problem
they're not actually fixing things why
is why do some doctors do that and i
love your kind of practice why do some
doctors do that though i think out of
habit when a patient comes in and says
you know i'm having a headache we'll
take this well you know i'm having
backache we'll take this and so what we
try to do jc is do preventative care in
the sense that we can try to clean up
all those medicines you take the doctors
keep adding to the bucket and they don't
want to stop something else because they
think it might work and dr bruno have
been in practice for many years and we
know the medications come with adverse
effects and you may not want to take
them all but a lot of the messes we
prescribe are wonderful products they
really help control imagine if i lowered
your blood pressure by 10 points i can
reduce your risk of having a stroke by
53 wow and so these are amazing numbers
and so our job as primary care providers
here in las vegas is to be a general
mechanic we provide transportation
wellness we have a physiotherapy part
physiotherapy where we give holistic
treatment not injections of steroids uh
platelet-rich plasma to help you able to
walk and reduce your fall risk really
it's a place to come get personalized
care the kind of care dr barba's been
providing here for years and what i love
about about you guys both las vegas 35
years 45 years your las vegas locals
we'd love that thank you so much for
joining us thanks for having us jason we
appreciate it thank you health for
sponsoring this segment they're located
at 4469 west charleston boulevard you
can call them at 702-848-2875